[Music]
grace joins us in saint george utah
grace welcome to the ramsay show
thank you so very much yeah how can we
help i'm excited i'm sorry so excited to
talk to you guys okay so i
just barely discovered you guys about a
little over two weeks ago oh wow and i
kind of stuck in the butt a little bit
so i had a financial advisor
tell me that i should file bankruptcy
and
kind of thinking about it and anyway my
friends showed me your show and i'm like
oh maybe they could have some good
advice for me and
point me in the right direction i'm
grateful you called us i know absolutely
so walk us through the situation how
much debt do you have
so
it's i think it's around seventy
thousand it's all credit card debt
all credit card
no credit card okay and what's your
income
so um i am i'm disabled
and
i've been to save it for about almost
three years
um my income is about when it's 23.99
2300 and
almost twenty four hundred dollars a
month okay a month
all right yeah
and what led you to to this point where
you're you've got 70 000 in credit card
debt and you're talking to the financial
advisor what kind of happened
so
so um
i can go out back in may of this year i
was served
served for one credit card debt that was
about 9 600.
and then recently again i was served for
um
another credit card debt
and on the first one i
i
talked with the finance of the company
that was
sued me and saying hey you know i can
pay payments
and i've always planned to be but i just
the date says no but won't satisfy us to
do that and so
i just didn't know what to do and i just
kind of let it slide
anyway about the second one my son's
like we've got to figure this out we've
got to figure out what we can do because
i am a single mother of eight living at
home
you say single mother of eight of eight
children
yeah and how many how many are living
with you right now all eight
all right okay
and you're taking care of them with that
2400 a month
well i do have i do get the stamps in
medical too
that um just recently since the first of
2020
they had the
um rental rental um assistant where you
could get mental assistance for coverage
yeah
and place with paid families and that's
kind of what kind of saved us a little
bit because they were just like this is
everything and we've already much lost a
lot of everything we had
so grace
can i ask what the nature of your
disability is you said it's been about
three years
okay
so um
my
so my first my first my husband died
and started with my mother my mother my
mother um
died like six months after i moved in
with her from cancer
and there was a victory from our home we
moved to
to our current
place right now
our current city right now and we had um
um so in order to survive we kind of
just i had really good credit i had i
was great made that really good i guess
we were
made up on the fico score so that's a
whole new thing to change in my mind but
i want to
anyway so i had really good credit i i
could track up cards if i wanted to i
mean but i came back i had was a
specialty nurse i you know i had an
excellent job
when i moved to my current location
um i
worked
full time plus two part-time job trying
to
did we lose her grace
hey there oh
you're okay
i'm so sorry you're going through all
this i mean you it's a lot crazy you
have had setback after setback after
heartbreak after heartbreak and let me
tell you the fact that you are where you
are taking care
of
your entire family i mean i'm just
inspired by you on one end
and heartbroken for you on another
and we we want to help walk you through
this and it's it's hard to do in a quick
radio call so here's what i want to do
for you grace i want to get you
connected to a financial coach who can
walk through your situation and to
answer your question
no you should not file bankruptcy right
now i believe you can get through this
you have 70 000 in credit card debt you
can clean up this mess
this is not beyond saving you are not
beyond saving and so if you hang on the
line
i'm going to have jenna pick up and
she's going to connect you with a
financial coach and we are going to pay
for that session for you you won't pay a
dime and on top of that i'm going to get
you connected to a ramsey plus
membership again we're going to pay for
that that's going to give you one year
access to financial peace university
every dollar our budgeting tool and i
want you to as you can make it through
that watch those videos
start to get a handle on a budget work
with your financial coach and they're
gonna walk
walk alongside you hold your hand and
get you out of the seventy thousand
dollars in credit card debt does that
sound good
you sure
that's great
i'm so sorry you're going through this i
know grace and and what what all this is
going to help you do because you do have
a lot i mean there's a lot um a lot of
dynamics here just in your story
um but also in your financial situation
but that we're going to be able to help
map out a plan for you
very clear and this financial coach will
help you set a budget
and to know okay here are all my
expenses and and have a level of control
over your money in the right way
that maybe you've never experienced
before grace but also i mean
um
i would also encourage you to if you i
hope you have family in the area or
a good church around you good friends
around you because
this can be a very isolating time for
you um
losing your husband and taking care of
kids i can't i can't even imagine um
all that you've walked through so i want
you also to think about
yourself and the healing process and the
grieving process and and to do that
really well and and again a good
counselor or a good pastor can walk with
you through that part as well because
that's
that's almost
more important you know than the money
stuff the money stuff adds so much
stress and hopefully we can remove some
of that by giving you that plan and you
can
walk through it but there's a lot there
grace and so um thank you so much though
for for calling in and i hope um and
jenna again will pick up and
we can connect you with what you need
that's a hard situation oh man and
rachel we did an episode on the fine
print the podcast that i hosted and the
episode's called is bankruptcy a quick
fix for struggling americans and i dug
into this and we hear stories we talk to
experts i want to encourage anyone who's
going through this thinking about it
check out this episode of the fine print
uh hopefully it educates some people and
helps show them that hope is out there
and this is not the only path and i know
the financial advisor wants this to be a
shortcut to get you on your feet but
there's another way and bankruptcy
doesn't have to be it